Speaker 1: It now appears as though George Santos
slash Anthony Davis older may have lied about his
COVID diagnosis. Everything has to be hyperbolic
with Santos, and he once claimed to be one of the
first people in the United States to be diagnosed
with COVID 19, which is like what? This is the
hallmark of pathological liars, where they lie
about things no one really cares about. Like
someone had to be one of the first people
diagnosed with COVID. Does it really matter
who it was? But he had the claim he was one of
those people. A Business Insider reports George
Santos claim to be one of the first people in the
US diagnosed with COVID. That looks to be bogus to
George Santos. His latest dubious claim involves a
COVID diagnosis from 2020. The timeline of testing
positive and getting sick differs in various
retellings of the story. His descriptions of
the severity of his illness have also changed
over time. The first case of COVID in New York
was confirmed on March 1st, 2020, and Santos
said in a conservative podcast he had symptoms
of COVID just a week later, around March 8th
or ninth. Unfortunately, on the 9th of March,
I became symptomatic with what we all know very
well COVID, a.k.a. Coronavirus, commonly known as
the Chinese Flu. On the 11th, I ended up in
the hospital. Really bad fever, body aches.
He said he was in a hospital in Queens. He was
there by ambulance, spent 5 hours in isolation,
had fever. He was hallucinating and ultimately
tested positive on March 14th and subsequently
negative on March 26th. But when he later talked
about the story, he had a different story,
both in terms of the severity and the timeline.
On the day Santos says he got a positive test,
he was bedridden with a fever. His campaign
put out a press release, including a quote
for him from him and didn't mention that he was
sick. It's kind of weird to put out a statement
about COVID on a day on which you're positive
and you're so sick you can't leave your bed and
you don't mention you have it. Four days later, he
was on Fox Business and he seems completely fine.
Very weird. And meanwhile, in a September
2020 interview with the Long Island outlet,
the Island now, he says the hospital
said, oh, just take some Advil or Aleve
and March 5th, 2021. He said on Twitter it was his
anniversary of going to the hospital for COVID,
but that lines up with a completely different
date. So he lied about his employment history.
He lied about his educational history. He lied
about his athletic acumen. He lied about being
Jewish from a family of Holocaust survivors. It
appears as though he also lied about the COVID 19
timeline. Really wacky and bizarre stuff.
I hope they do destroy his career because
he deserves to have it destroyed. Now, I'm not
saying he shouldn't work and he should starve,
okay? He should have his career in the position
that he obtained based on lying about everything.
Destroyed that career. He can go back and, you
know, if he thinks that he's a finance guy,
even though those were lies. Go. Go back and work
in finance or, you know, get some job somewhere
else. But the job he got on the basis of the lies
he should lose. And let's hope that that happens.